the answer here is maybe right the best
part of 2023 is we've gotten to the part
of the world where not everybody thinks
that every kid should go to college
um which really hurt a lot of people on
the flip side there's a lot of
entrepreneurial kids that really need to
go to college to work on their social
skills to learn some more and uh
meet new people that might become their
entrepreneurial Partners the reality is
that for a kid that's incredibly great
at entrepreneurship and if they were
forced to go to college because their
parents wanted them to or the ideology
of the world wanted them to and they
were to collect a hundred thousand
dollars in debt during that time not
really learning that many things because
they were already remarkably super
talented like a LeBron or Kobe in
entrepreneurship maybe that person
shouldn't so the reality is is it comes
down to many yeses and many no's and
most of all it may be here there's no
absolute answer you have to reverse
engineer the actual situation